[Music]
sickness in the aftermath of the floods
the discomfort too great for a
two-year-old to comprehend
her family says she cries all night
[Music]
our children are sick look at her they
are vomiting a lot and have diarrhea
doctors come from time to time and give
medicines but they don't seem like
enough some are getting better but some
are getting sicker
help is limited to piecemeal local
efforts for now
desperation leaving no room for decorum
[Music]
those too small or too weak to brave the
crowd
are left to console each other
even volunteers admit whatever they are
doing is not enough
there is a lot of need here but as far
as our capacity goes the population of
the entire region has come here one
person cannot do everything alone
displaced by the floods people here have
been living like this for weeks still
some say they are the lucky ones
in more remote areas cut off and
stranded people have nothing
the main problem now local leaders say
is draining standing water to prevent
disease and give people a way home
but the more immediate need is to keep
them alive
to survive for these people living in
these villages they need tents
they need food items and we are trying
to make packages for each family so that
they can survive for a week and then
again we'll give them another packet
next week this is how we are planning to
make sure they survive
the message is be patient help is coming
but there have been protests and people
are angry that it has taken so long to
address the aftermath of monsoon rains
that have been pouring down for two
months flood survivors are setting up
makeshift camps but many of them arrive
to safer ground without even a tarp to
hang over their heads they're living out
in the open the sun is going down and
this is how so many people across the
province will sleep tonight and more
than likely many more nights to come
zain basravi al-jazeera larkana district
sindh pakistan